[Musik]
janina vielen dank dass ich auch heute
abend bei viertel nach acht über die
situation hier in der ukraine sprechen
kann und tatsächlich ich war heute
nachmittag in einem präsidentenpalast
aber dort sieht es nicht mehr aus wie
ein präsidentenpalast aus sieht man geht
doch rein das licht ist aus man fällt
fast über die treppe und dann sieht man
überall sandsäcke aufgestellt und man
denkt in jedem moment gibt es hier eine
attacke und plötzlich kommt aus irgend
einem anderen raum bludenz geräumt und
ist erstaunlich entspannt und fragt wie
geht es ihnen eigentlich wie geht es
ihnen denn kehrt aber dann ging es
natürlich um sehr ernste themen ich habe
ihn gefragt wie viel angst der
eigentlich um sein eigenes leben hat und
was mit seinen kindern hat ist seine
älteste tochter ist 18 jahre alt und er
hat gesagt meine kinder sind stolz dass
wir weiterhin hier sind und er will
bleiben er will weiter bleiben in seinem
land und er denkt nicht an eine flucht
und ganz unabhängig davon muss man sagen
dass er erneut ein sehr dramatischen
appell an die westliche welt gerichtet
hat er hat diesen satz gesagt wir
sterben auch für euch seine aussage und
seine meinung ist dass das was gerade in
der ukraine passiert sehr schnell auch
anderen ländern passieren kann dass wenn
putin hier mit der ukraine fertig ist
dass es weiter geht ins baltikum also in
die nato-staaten und immer weiter und
immer weiter deswegen seine mahnung und
warnung und auch wenn er mittlerweile
gelernt hat diplomatisch zu sein habe
ich herausgehört bei ihm wie wütend er
ist auf deutschland wie wütend er ist
auf olaf scholz den kanzler wie wütend
er darauf ist dass es immer noch aus
seiner sicht keine wirklich klare
antwort darauf gibt dass es in sachen
eu-beitritt keine mögliche schnelle
perspektive gibt und dass aus sicht der
ukraine weiterhin nicht genügend
westliche waffen hier sind denn das ist
das entscheidende für die ukraine
momentan die frage wie gut können sie
sich verteidigen denn dann kommt es
darauf an wie es an ende bei
verhandlungen aussieht und bei diesen
verhandlungen dass man eine sache nie
vergessen wladimir putin hat vor zwei
wochen ungefähr als dieser krieg
begonnen hat gesagt die ukraine die gibt
ist eigentlich gar nicht sie gehört zu
russland und das ist der ausgangspunkt
von dem sie lenski auf dem sie das
gesteht und wir saßen dort auf diesen
treppen und es war eine für mich völlig
skurrile absurde situation mit einem
präsidenten ein interview zu führen der
natürlich in so einer situation kein
schlips trägt aber der ja fast
camouflage trägen und wie auf einer
treppe sitzen und rundherum um uns
sandsäcke sind
paul du wirst ja immer die großen
interviews mit vielen staatsmännern mit
politikern du bist es ja an für sich
gewöhnt solche interviews zu führen das
hier war jetzt etwas komplett anderes
was war der emotionalste moment für dich
oder der moment wo du wirklich was sie
lange in erinnerung bleiben wird
die frage nach den kindern von selensky
weil er auch ein lustiger mensch ist
eigentlich es gibt so tolle videos von
ihnen von früher in der
internationalen version von let's dance
hat er mitgemacht er ist ja eigentlich
zufällig politiker geworden jemand der
immer im showbusiness unterwegs war
komiker war schauspieler war und jetzt
sitzt dieser mann dort in den
präsidentenpalast und ist im krieg und
ich frage ihn was ist mit seinen kindern
was ist wenn die ihm sagen putin will
dich töten papa gesagt nein meine kinder
sind stolz auf mich dass ich hier bin
und sie sind auch hier war das ganze
land hier ist und das drückt aus was die
ukraine momentan fühlt die gesamte
ukraine führt dass sie angegriffen
werden aber dass sie zusammenstehen dass
alle familien zusammen stehen und dass
sie sich die existenz nicht absprechen
lassen
ich würde hier gerne die runde dann
eröffnen weil es uns den ganzen abend
wie immer live zugeschaltet paul wie
immer geh einfach auch rein herr heißen
ich würde gerne die frage an sie geben
machen wir genug
wenn man das jetzt auch die eindrücke
von paul wie verhält sich deutschland
gerade aus ihrer sicht als cdu politiker
also ich glaube wir mal nicht genug aber
erstmal also wirklich hochachtung vor
der journalistischen leistung von paul
ronzheimer ich habe auf dem weg hierher
mir dieses interview auch live angesehen
mit dem präsidenten das ist wirklich
enorm beeindruckend und man fühlt
richtig mit auch mit den ukrainern in
dieser schwierigen situation das ist
also ich finde das eine ganz ganz krasse
situation einfach dass wir wieder krieg
in europa haben auch gerade für die
junge generation aber nein wir tun als
deutschland nicht genug und ich meine
wir sind ja im moment als wir müssen
auch wegkommen von dieser gewissen
naivität die wir glaube ich zu lange
hatten gerade im umgang mit putin diese
sogenannten putin verstehe ja das ist
etwas was wir uns einfach überhaupt
nicht mehr leisten können in deutschland
und es ist ja im moment sogar die
absurde situation dass der hier noch
verdient an seinem krieg weil die
gaspreise weiter steigen und russland
eben einer der größten gasexporteur ist
und dass das kann es ja nicht sein das
müssen wir beenden deswegen also
mindestens müssen wir nord stream 1
abschaffen damit er zumindest auch
gezwungen ist das gas noch weiter durch
osteuropa zu leiten und so schnell wie
möglich müssen wir ganz weg kommen vom
russischen gas das ist ein ganz
entscheidender punkt jetzt putin
verstehe ist ein gutes stichwort ich
würde gerne an herr molten mich wenden
erneuten es gibt ja in deutschland und
vor allem auch in ihrer früheren partei
der afd ja auch nach wie vor menschen
die eigentlich putin verherrlichen wie
gefährlich ist das für unsere demokratie
ja ich halte das für hoch gefährlich
aber lassen so dass er mit der
ehemaligen partei es ist eine ehemalige
also ich spreche für mich und ich eine
lange taten hatten glaube ich dessen
verdächtigter eine verherrlichung von
putin zu machen ich würde das geld
wieder sprechen das ist immer klug wenn
man versucht andere zu verstehen und
putin zu verstehen finde ich nicht
schlimm verständnis dafür zu haben das
ist das was indiskutabel ist wir müssen
die abläufe verstehen das problem ist
dass man ihm keinesfalls für das was er
getan hat irgendeine form von
verständnis entgegenbringen kann denn
was er da macht ist etwas was globale
auswirkungen haben kann das schlimmste
das schlimmste ist die botschaft für
alle skrupellosen machthaber dieser welt
dass krieg zum zweck territoriale
ausdehnung wieder als mögliches mittel
der politik betrachtet wird und erste
nachahmer
melden bereits ihre ansprüche an und das
ist etwas fatales damit endet eine ära
des relativen friedens und auch eine
einer friedens gesinnung und das ist das
was mir besondere sorge macht bei der
ganzen geschichte nicht trotzdem hier an
dieser stelle noch einmal nachhaken weil
ich es so gefährlich auch für unser land
finde sie sind sie stehen natürlich für
sich selbst und ich akzeptiere es auch
sehr dass sie auch ausgetreten sind aber
wie stark ist die afg denn für mein
eigenes verständnis unterwandert auch
mit putin verstehen und wie gefährlich
ist dass man ist ja gewöhnt dass dort
auch nazis sind aber jetzt auch noch
menschen die eigentlich ja was putin tut
in ordnung sind fast schon verherrlichen
sie bringen da hinein auf dem ich
eigentlich gar nicht einsteigen will
weil noch einmal das ist nicht meine
partei ich habe eine entscheidung
getroffen die hat übrigens auch damit zu
tun und damit mache ich mir das auch
nicht mehr zu eigen und fernsehen bei
mir auf granit beißen ich äußere mich zu
fd nicht mehr in ort darf ich mal kurz
also ich meine das ist ja der klassische
trick den wir leider gewöhnt sind sowohl
in ihrem widerspruch habt ja ganz
bewusst so genannte putin versteher
gesagt weil man jetzt damit so
sämtlichen feinheiten auf die sich dann
kapriziert wird es geht natürlich darum
dass leute ganz stark auch aus der afd
und eben auch in der zeit als sie deren
sprecher waren verständnis geäußert
haben für wladimir putin schlimmer noch
die afg an einem bundestagsabgeordneten
von dem putin gesagt hat er stehe unter
oder russland stehe unter vollständiger
kontrolle des kreml ja es gibt in
landtagsabgeordneten hier in berlin der
gesagt hat der putin als engen freund
bezeichnet hat und so weiter es gibt
viele derartige beispiele und das ist
natürlich in der zeit passiert in der
sie sprecher waren
wenn dieser trend eine wenn ich eine
sache kurz sagen darf na ja
also bitte ermorden ich habe jetzt
einfach mal ja ich habe nebenbei einfach
mal mir angeschaut was sie zur
wiederwahl von wladimir putin gesagt
haben wenn ich das mal vorlesen darf
zitat wir gratulieren war die mir putin
zu seiner wiederwahl zum russischen
staatspräsidenten wir wünschen ihm viel
erfolg und politische umsicht für seine
nächste amtsperiode die afg wird sich
nach wie vor für einen dialog mit
russland auf augenhöhe ansetzen und
alles daran setzen dass die deutsch
russischen beziehungen zu einer
konstruktiven normalität zurückkehren
dazu hat auch die für beide seiten
schädlichen sanktionen abzubauen und
jetzt hören sie doch mal auf davon zu
reden dass das ihre ex partei ist das
haben sie gesagt das ist doch ihre
meinung hören sie doch auf sich jetzt
von der afg dazu entfernen sie waren hat
putin treuen und jetzt tun sie so als
wären sie das nicht mehr heraus als
parteivorsitzender gratuliert man
menschen die gewählt wurden wurden im
relevanten nationen das tue ich auch
dass es eine selbstverständlichkeit habe
ich die ach so und da sagen dass man
sanktionen sagen dass man sagt man auch
dass man die sanktion nicht mehr möchte
in einer situation wo bereits klar war
dass wladimir putin der aggressor ist wo
wladimir putin ganz klar die ukraine
einen krieg geführt hat bereits erneuten
ich habe diesen krieg hier seit acht
jahren erlebt im osten ist kind nicht
allein erst los ihrem pferd es war schon
im osten seit jahren extra sie haben
sich dafür eingesetzt dass die
sanktionen nicht mehr stattfinden
sollten haben sie doch mal auf
sie chauffierten sich ganz heftig aber
lassen sie mich bitte auch ausreden wenn
ich sage dass es sinnvoll ist in einem
konstruktiven dialog zwischen nationen
zu sein dann ist das sinnvoll sie haben
sich dafür ausgesprochen dass die
sanktionen abgeschafft werden soll haben
wir ja noch was haben die sanktionen
denn gebracht was haben sie gebracht in
welcher situation sind wir heute denken
sie da die sagen was ihnen waren nicht
scharf genug die sanktion war nicht
scharf genug und deswegen konnte putin
das überhaupt tun was er hier tue
therapeuten sie sind mit ihrer politik
mitverantwortlich mit ihrem relativismus
dass die situation so ist wie sie gerade
ist also dass das ist wirklich eine
absurdität nicht zu überbieten lieber
herr uns einmal in aller deutlichkeit es
ist nicht zu überbieten es ist quatsch
was wir da sein erklärt sie das nochmal
noch einmal es ist sinnvoll einen dialog
zu suchen es ist auch sinnvoll für
europäer mit russland dialog zu suchen
das sollte man tun da sollte man übrigen
aber dann erklären sie doch einmal warum
sie die sanktionen abschaffen wollten zu
diesem zeitpunkt bereits weil wir keinen
zweck hatten um in den dialog
zurückzufinden der wenn er stattgefunden
hätte die situation heute vielleicht
etwas anders darstellt als sie sich
heute dasteht was wir jedoch erleben ist
ein scheitern des westens auf der ganzen
linie
das ist einfach so und deswegen haben
sie auch deswegen haben sie auch
wahlbeobachter nach russland geschickt
auf die krim geschickt deswegen haben
sie mit putin gekuschelt über all die
jahre hatte ich will bush junior darum
eine frühe und die lage wurde sein
beobachter auf ja doch herr uns ein
verzicht auf solche wenn sie wenn sie
wenn sie wenn sie sich dafür aussprechen
dass die sanktion abgeschafft werden
doch in einer zeit in der putin bereits
krieg geführt es geht um sanktionen in
einer zeit wo wladimir putin bereits
krieg in der ost ukraine geführt hat und
sie haben sich dafür ausgesprochen dass
diese sanktionen abgeschafft werden soll
sie haben wahlbeobachter hingeschickt
und haben sich von der propaganda von
wladimir putin einnehmen lassen und sie
waren damals als parteivorsitzender
dafür verantwortlich und jetzt können
sie nicht sagen nein da habe ich gar
nichts mit zu tun dass meine frühere
partei sie waren parteivorsitzender
herunter dann müssten wir über das reden
was in diesen acht jahren im don was
passiert ist das separate geschichte ich
bin 12 und davon sehr gerne davon
ausgegangen dass wir an dieser sendung
über die aktuelle situation sprechen und
in der aktuellen situation sage ich
ihnen die aktuelle situation hat sehr
viel damit lässt sich außerdem welche
politik in deutschland passiert ist ich
lasse sie gerne aus aber über erregung
er was erzählen aber man muss ich muss
ich auch ausreden lassen die brauchte
eine ehre von ihnen erneuten ich brauche
keine ehre was ist denn das für ein stil
also wie war noch nicht miteinander um
ich verstehe ihre ihre hohe erregung und
ich verstehe dass sie dass sie dann sehr
schweren job derzeit verrichten aber
deswegen kann man das mit meinen sie
nicht auch verlangt berlin aufwändig in
berlin sitzen würde herr wollten würde
ich ihnen das genauso ins gesicht sagen
so einer situation hinzu die situation
die wir heute haben ist nun auf meine ex
parteien und handy zurück zu finden die
wir niemals in irgendeiner
regierungsverantwortung so die situation
haben wir und das sind viele fehler
gemacht hat
es wurden fundamentale fehler auf
russischer seite gemacht worden das sind
fundamentale fehler auf seiten des
westens gemacht worden man hat den kurs
des dialoges verlassen und das war ein
fehler und den können wir jetzt
durchdeklinieren ich glaube nur dass in
einer situation wie der jetzigen
besser uns die zeit damit die zeit
besser damit verwenden dass wir uns
fragen was ist denn jetzt zu tun als
eine analyse der vergangenen acht jahre
die hilf uns nämlich in der jetzigen
situation kein bisschen weiter für
welche sanktionen sind sie denn jetzt
erneuten wenn wir jetzt in der iss zeit
sind wofür sind sie jetzt ich halte die
aktuellen sanktionen die von der
bundesregierung ergriffen wurden für
notwendig und richtig
ich habe keine großen illusionen dass
sie eine
veränderung der situation im kreml
hervorrufen werden aber was wäre die
alternative die alternative wäre nichts
zu tun und nichts zu tun das können wir
uns in der stadt so nicht leisten und
das ist genau das fatale signal dass wir
dann an die aggressoren der welt
schicken also müssen wir sagen wir
müssen etwas tun wenn wir nicht
militärisch eingreifen dann in der tat
kommen um die sanktionen nicht herum die
sanktionen gilt sind sehr weitreichend
und hält sie für richtig
kommen wir zu ihnen sie hatten jetzt
noch gar keine zeit etwas zu sagen was
ist es mit was glauben sie die
sanktionen welche wie wie können wir das
stoppen wie können wir diesen
widerlichen ich möchte auch einfach mal
sagen aggressor putin stoppen also ich
glaube dass das scheitern und das hat
herr uns er unterstrich das scheitern
lag darin dass nach 2014 nach den
tabubrüchen der annexion der krim eines
brutalen krieges im dombach dem
eingreifen von russland 2015 in syrien
die unterstützung für eine politik von
azad die genau das vorgezeichnet hat was
wir heute sehen also die eroberung von
aleppo durch bombardierungen durch
vertreibung der bevölkerung eine
verbrannte erde und dann das entvölkerte
territorium zurückholen auf all diese
aggressionen hat der gesamte westen hat
deutschland haben aber auch viele andere
europäische länder nicht reagiert und
das bedeutet dass bis drei wochen bis
vor drei wochen bis kurz vor dem krieg
branimir putin jede menge gründe hatte
zu erwarten dass auch diesmal keine
sanktionen folgen also die abschreckung
hat dieses mal vor allem deswegen nicht
geklappt weil bis vor wenigen wochen ein
viktor orban nach moskau gereist ist und
in der presse gesagt hat ungarn ist
gegen sanktionen in der österreichischen
politik gesagt wurde vom außenminister
und anderen nord stream 2 steht nicht
zur debatte in italien vom
premierminister mario draghi gesagt
wurde also sanktionen bringen gar nichts
europa hat keinen einfluss und diese
kombination natürlich die deutsche
debatte haben wir alle verfolgt wie
schwierig es war
neben den putin freund mit der fdp und
den putin freunden in der linkspartei
auch für parteien der mitte sicher klar
zu positionieren und das hat den
eindruck und er war fatal hinterlassen
putin kann diese kriege weiterführen er
wird keinen preis bezahlen der westen
wird sich wieder mit ihm arrangieren und
als sich 2015 mosca war für einige zeit
da waren war die überraschung bei vielen
meiner gesprächspartner gerade auch
leute die dem kreml nahe standen
warum haben die deutschen hiphop
sanktionen überhaupt die schwachen
sanktionen die es nach 2015 gab wir
haben erwartet mit den deutschen macht
man geschäfte die beteiligen sich nicht
das ist etwas amerikanisches und ich
glaube das war der fatale fehler und
wenn wir etwas lernen müssen dann dass
das komplett ignorieren von jeglicher
form von moral in der außenpolitik am
ende auch nicht gut fürs geschäft ist
denn jetzt stehen all diese firmen ob
total die großen energie firmen alle die
die in russland investieren haben stehen
jetzt vor den scherben ihrer politik
denn natürlich brauchen wir einen rahmen
ein internationales system und das
wladimir putin dieses system zerstören
wollte das ist schon seit über einem
jahrzehnt eigentlich offensichtlich aber
er konnte in der illusion weiter agieren
das eben der westen auch deutschland
auch die eu das durchgehen lässt